[Música]
para a galera tranquila tranqüilo
qualquer apresentar o meu personagem do
jogo world of warcraft
vocês conhecem algum laço em 2004 jogo
desde que lançou o racionais mc's em meu
xodó
a obra veio daí pra ver a quantidade de
horas que eu tenho só que esse
personagem hora de jogo
abraão eu tentar facilitar
são 90 dias de jogo só com esse
personagem e gestão petista está a 90
vezes 24 horas dois mil cento e tantas
horas de jogo só com esse personagem é
importante dizer que eu não só comprei
jogo eu paguei todas as expansões
subseqüentes e eu pago desde quatro
mensagens para jogar esse jogo eu pago
por um trabalho de meio expediente
mas mesmo assim mesmo sendo gamer
hardcore jogando muito e um
desenvolvedor
acho muito difícil falar de games saibro
e começa a falar de games começar porque
são tantas a diferença tanto preconceito
aí eu falo de games a pessoa tem na
cabeça aquele jogo específico em um
momento nostálgico
aquele jogo jogos meus filhos hoje elas
tiveram mil anos atrás muito mais gente
que fala o esporte eletrônico o jogo
muito prático e tal
o sport hoje o esporte supera o sport
convencional em termos de visibilidade e
por causa disso tudo só vai pensar que o
atleta digital pode jogar toda hora
jogando e jogando tem que pensar no chão
no processo desenvolvimento como a
possibilidade de investimento talvez né
já no brasil mas a sociedade com certeza
mas já tem muita gente que pensa ninguém
uma brincadeira descompromissado leva
ninguém a lugar nenhum mas duas coisas
certas
primeiro é uma indústria bilionária
supera a indústria da música e do cinema
juntos superam os ganhos em tudo quanto
é lugar
termina em diversos campos segundo quase
ninguém fala de games e pensa a educação
pelo contrário os ganhos são arqui
inimigos da educação para muita gente
mas ele a idéia é que o sistema de games
quase um sábio com vasto é esse universo
então o que falar um pouco de número
chama xuxa vocês são joão já pedindo 2.2
bilhões de games ativo de um ativo não é
aquela pessoa que jogava com a criança
para jogar não sei que jogam com
freqüência freqüência seis horas por
semana
o tempo médio gasto com games o game
quando esse número cheio ridícula olhar
é possível que é muito mais que um amigo
meu que o youtube rio e falou assim cara
para isso é errado vou ligar pra ele vai
pensar diferente perfis de games
esses dois milhões de gamers e de
diferentes tipos diferentes tribos
diferentes
quantas coisas uma pessoa sair 70 anos
têm em comum em termos de rob com essa
freqüência com garotos de 10 anos não é
tão pouco assim seis horas sai a chegar
à conclusão que os games engajam os
games engajam milene os games engajo tá
mas o que é alguém que essa pergunta o
que alguém é o digital não todos os
jogos dos físicos aos digitais games
todos os jogos
possui três características que chamam
de fazer com essas três características
o primeiro objetivo
o objetivo no jogo ao jogador precisa
focar pode ser a cesta de basquete
como pode ser aquele dragão aquele
chefão que tem que derrotar pode ser só
não perder é um objetivo fim de beck não
se chama de retorno o jogador precisa
saber do progresso de desenvolvimento
dele naquele jogo né pontuação por
exemplo serra e voluntariedade porque
nenhum jogo obrigatório não pode obrigar
alguém a jogar tem que jogar por livre e
espontânea vontade
são com essas três características que
os jogos tenham ganchos motivacionais e
assim em gaza os jogadores participantes
esses ganhos motivacionais com diversas
motivações mas pensamentos motivações
intrínsecas exemplo prático para
explicar o que melhora um pouco mais se
sabe questão da motivação e engajamento
muito a sentença
vocês já ouviram falar de sísifo se
furtou a falar hoje à grega civil foi
condenado por uma rocha em uma montanha
de novo de novo e de novo
toda vez que chegava lá aonde a cair de
novo essa punição dele um exemplo claro
de trabalho inútil
lembre-se disso já ouviram falar de
guerra em over this fire é um jogo
alguém alguém uma pessoa gay mehr
a gente troca idéia nesse jogo você tem
que escalar a montanha
usando um martelo mas a qualquer momento
você pode cair e começar do zero
perdendo horas de jogo
oras perdeu 0 acabou é outra chance a
não fosse suficiente o narrador narra
todos os seus erros deixando claro que
você mandou mal começa de novo e de novo
vocês parecem maneiro e 6 1
nesse jogo vendeu milhares de cópias
como point e um exemplo os dois são
muito parecidos dois exemplos mas em 1 a
1 punição divina e no outro um jogo de
sucesso
a resposta está na motivação intrínseca
à chamada motivação 3.0 assistir três
áreas também maestria a sua vontade
sempre aos melhores dominar uma
habilidade propósito claro que o poço
pode variar segundo os jogos mas se a
direção sabe o que fazer um desvio
ambição fazer uma coisa e fazer um
sentido e autonomia se manifesta
decisões escolhi nosso senso de
liberdade
essas seis raias que os games trabalho
muito bem feito e quando quero falar de
game fixação de uma técnica que é
aplicar a astrein espera que estes games
objetivo feedback voluntariedade e um
conteúdo ou experiência para assim criar
os ganchos motivacionais
nessas três áreas a outras áreas está
não quer reduzir os games a isso
mecânicas que geram grandes
multinacionais mas a idéia é essa
assim que eles se engajem ea
dignificação que pode ser que é uma
técnica não se trata de um épico
tecnologia é uma técnica pode ser
analógica trabalho é isso na vila real
está mais vivo que teve a educação cara
como esse ajuda do cação tempo tag certo
olha uma foto em 1900 1908 assim em 1900
de aula há pelo menos 200 anos ou seja
antes essa foto bem antes que o atual
sistema de ensino
o mesmo trabalha um tipo de inteligência
e visa instaurar qualidades desejadas
por um sistema de produção já em
declínio e que disciplina a resiliência
respeito à autoridade a foco no fim os
alunos chegam à sala de aula sendo
enfileirados não pra frente
o professor supostamente a única fonte
de informação pleno século 21 está mas é
a única formação que a vida lhe enchem
de cor a aguentar duas horas dias ou
meses para passar na prova e finalmente
essa prova que não prova nada né que
avalia de forma binária simplista e
reducionista porque a aluna aquela
matéria que valeriam é isso aí você que
foi isso aqui
esses meses todos aqui você é isso e
depois eles mandarem bem nessa avaliação
se eles mandarem bem ser acusado porque
agora você é o melhor ou pior que um
amigo é isso aqui competição negativa
é esse cenário que é o sistema oposto
dos games
tem um posto já perceberam que nos games
nós passamos a maior parte do tempo
perdendo a partida perdendo só perde a
sua pele
na verdade você não só pede como você
pega um jogo sem encarar aquela curva de
aprendizado ou seja é um jogo novo tem
que aprender
eu aprendo pra perder mas é isso é o que
se aprende a coalhada é muito e peço que
a jornada é isso aí você arte mas mas
quando ele finalmente consegue superar o
desafio parece que tudo valeu a pena
cara andei muito sol da língua
o processo vale a pena o processo vale a
pena porque nos games
você tem esse contingente atrito entre o
que sabemos o que sabemos que precisamos
saber para progredir novamente nada que
chame de ensino o aluno a gente não sabe
que muita gente não sabe que ele vai
aprender a conhecer aprender
ele sabe muito bem de quantificar essa
que ele é bom né cara faz quatro anos
faculdade fala aí janeiro sem muito
agora vou usar isso aproveite o composto
é que eu pegar o progredir assim ó mas
game você tem essa noção
essa informação serve pra isso nesse
sentido de quem vai fazer muito pelo
ensino muito não é só promover o
engajamento maior com aprendizado
a vontade de aprender mas é uma imersão
naquele processo
cara eu faço parte disso o pertencimento
66 sabem equipe geral conhece ela
conhece igreja já fala que o ic tem
várias páginas em que disse aquilo que o
outro de filme é a maior riqueza do
mundo se reunirão até hoje e eu falei
gol do boca nome que num can é nada mais
que isso
mas só que é compartilhar isso porque
ele sabe que o pessoal pesquisa eu sei
que eu preciso na hora
até hoje eu quero aprender
essa paixão só a vontade de aprender
esse processo a gente pode fazer um
cenário uma possibilidade é a
dignificação da experiência sala de aula
com as competências emocionais
sabe aquelas curiosidade liderança
colaboração autocontrole aquela gente
que chama assume que os alunos vão
aprender automaticamente à porta da
escola na avenida vai ver isso aí que
não é justamente isso que fizemos na
escola estadual chico em uso
pegamos o conteúdo de história terceiro
ano eo limite com as competências
emocionais os alunos virar agente para
aprendizado
aquele cartaz pessoal está no fundo aqui
o jogo está na identificação analógica
aquele jogo aqui o negócio foi a
professora passa mas é isso
já pensando na decisão aquela primeira
aula sem ter que escolher um chapão para
derrotar o agente o aprendizado ea aula
expositiva reduzido a professora para
guiar por pistas e não migalhas
o aluno tem que buscar e expor o
conhecimento com o próprio ferramental
responder com um já tenho um fantoche
com música quer criar muito se quiser
favor trabalho o chip de inteligência
responda quando você quiser manifeste a
sua existência porque o jogo possibilita
assim começa a edificação a inúmeras
outras implicações analógicas na rede
pública de ensino
vale muito a pena ver sérgio recomenda
porque deixam claro mostra que não é
necessário grande investimento ea parati
uma verdadeira revolução no sistema
educacional promover o engajamento
imersão não já é hora
de acabar com o preconceito em relação
às possibilidades profissionais da
indústria de games que são muitas
surgiram no youtube saiu recentemente
sete anos o milionário paralela de
xingang já é hora de acabar com o
preconceito nas instituições e acabar
com você em relação à dengue como
ferramenta educacional e social
é hora de legitimar os games de ensino e
fazer a jogada certa na sala de aula
obrigado a sair
[Música]